c'est la dernière demande de volotemir
Zelenski après la pluie de missile qui
s'est abattu sur l'Ukraine la création
d'un dôme de défense aérienne grâce à la
internationale
je vous demande de renforcer les forces
général pour aider financièrement à la
création d'un bouclier aérien pour
l'Ukraine
des milliers de personnes seront
reconnaissantes au G7 pour une telle
assistance une ennemi militaire
internationale très hétéroclite en
fonction des pays membres du G7 les
États-Unis sont loin devant avec plus de
27 milliards d'euros d'aide militaires
depuis le début du conflit le
Royaume-Uni lui a envoyé l'équivalent de
4 milliards d'euros d'équipements et de
fonds c'est plus que la Pologne
l'Allemagne et surtout la France accusée
par certains de ne pas en faire assez
avec ses 233 millions d'euros d'aide
militaires Emmanuel Macron a promis ces
derniers jours d'accroître le soutien à
l'Ukraine la France envisage l'envoi de
six canons César complémentaires en plus
des 18 déjà livrés pour sa défense
aérienne l'Ukraine va aussi recevoir le
système entier aérien allemand iris
ainsi qu'une batterie de huit lanceurs
naza américain
nous travaillons dur pour leur fournir
les deux premiers nasams
nous pensons que nous pourrons les
envoyer dans un avenir proche
au total plus de 40 milliards d'euros
d'aide militaires ont été envoyés à
l'Ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
par près de 40 pays différents